- So Aria, you
are a transgender,
Kosher,
Conservative Jew
and a bioengineer scientist.
How do you exist?
- Well, it's been a struggle.
I've had to fight
to exist, actually.
- So you grew up religious?
- Reform.
- You grew up a Reform Jew
which to the laypeople
watching at home
means grew up
listening to techno.
How did you make a transition
from Reform to Conservative?
- Well, in college I
actually started going
to a Hasidic synagogue
on the weekends
really just to find
out more about myself
and about Jewish mysticism
because I had some questions
and obviously I was questioning
more than I thought.
- Why'd you leave Reform Judaism
and go towards
Conservative Judaism?
Wouldn't Reform have been
more accepting and loving
towards your transition?
- Especially.
Especially in my family.
None of my family members
are as conservative as I am.
- That's crazy!
- So I go home and
I'm like, no Mom,
I'm not eating pork.
Why do you guys do this to me?
And then they complain
of stomach aches.
- You said that in
such a Jewish way:
"And then they complained
of stomach aches.
I'm like, well?"
Would you say you eat more
lox as a man or a woman?
- That never changed,
that's always constant.
- That's a steady...
- Just every week.
(laughs)
- What is your perspective
on homosexuality?
- Well it's changed, actually.
I was actually very
homophobic before
and only had relationships
with women, as a man,
for a long time.
And recently, as my
body has changed a lot,
all of my assumptions
have been challenged.
I think my attraction
has also been changed
or affected by the transition.
- Orientation and
gender-identity are separate.
- My mom does not
agree with that.
- Your mom thinks
what, you're gay?
- She wishes I
was gay, probably.
- You were tired
of the testosterone
that was biologically
pumping through your body
and what did you choose to do?
- And the hair, I mean
I had a huge hair issue.
- You're a Jew!
I mean that's not
a gender thing.
I just want to show you
how bad it could have been.
- Should I touch it?
- Feel free.
- I used to be very
scared of this.
I would think that
everybody was staring
at my nude forearms or something
but then I wore a
small-faced watch.
It was one of the first things
that I did to crossdress.
- One of the first feminine
things that you did.
And what was that feeling
like, when you first did that?
- Guilty.
- You felt guilt.
- I was a dude.
- But was it thrilling?
- Oh of course.
- So it was guilt and thrill?
- Yeah, and I would go back
every day and crossdress.
And it would be
this repeating cycle
until I decided I didn't
want to just crossdress.
- Are you a scientist
first, or a Jew first,
or a trans woman first?
What's the most important
identity marker for you?
- Musician.
- Musician!
I didn't know that
was available.
What kind of music do you make?
- I'm a pianist and I
like EDM production.
- Oh you like techno?
- Yeah.
- I told you it was
about techno, guys.
Why not be in a more funky,
liberal strain of Judaism
that would automatically
accept your gender identity?
- Doesn't appeal to me.
I really want something that's
deep and connected to God
and an inspiring way that
reminds me of the ancient times
and really what a lot of
history has been leading to.
And of course, like a lot of
Jews want the Messiah to come.
Moshiach; you know all
about that I'm sure.
- I mean, I'm thinking
I might be that person.
- Exactly.
- I just got my own
show on Comedy Central.
There's nothing holding me
back from revealing myself.
- Exactly, just take off
those glasses and then, boom!
- Wait, why I gotta
take off the glasses?
This is what the Jewish
Messiah would look like.
- It's not like X-Men.
- I'm here! Ugh.
I'll get to you -
that's what he'd say.
Thank you for coming in.
And now that we've
figured out how you exist,
I'm glad that you exist.
- Thank you so much.